so let's assume you want to be
successful and when I mean by successful
I don't mean like I want to be
successful no you know about the hard
work to sacrifice to you know yours of
what it's gonna take for you to be alone
and you know you want to be successful
and you're willing to do to work let's
assume that okay here's a few things you
need to be doing you need to realize
your parents don't know everything your
family doesn't know everything your
friends don't know everything you don't
know everything your teachers don't know
everything and as you're going about
wanting to become successful you have to
know that your friends parents family
teachers many of them are going to
impose three things on you fears facts
opinions okay and you are gonna get
judged based on how you differentiate
between those three I know this is a
little bit of a technical message so let
me say it one more time you want to be
successful you want to win big you know
you're gonna put in the work the
sacrifice all that other stuff
throughout the journey of you going out
there wanted to win big your parents
your friends your teachers your
co-workers people gonna impose their
opinions on and they're gonna be based
on three different things fears facts
opinions right your job is to be able to
differentiate between the three let me
explain to you you want to go out and
start a business and you want to be a
millionaire your parents may impose
their own fears on you based on prior
failures they had that cost them a
marriage or relationship of friendship
and it was humiliating and you need to
know that what your parents are telling
you is a fear not a fact okay on another
situation your parents could be giving
you a fact and telling you be cautious
about Bitcoin because the article I read
here was an investigation done on that
that thought that thought that's a fact
that's not a fear you may be deciding to
get into real estate financial industry
insurance stocks bonds you know digital
marketing whatever it may be
pharmaceutical sales somebody may give
you their opinion and say my opinion is
I wouldn't do pharmaceutical sale
because of dot dot dot dot dot now that
opinion is not 100 percent it's an
opinion you have the ability to say he
makes a good point with that opinion I
don't know if I agree with them on that
opinion fears facts up
by the way you know which one typically
gets people to not pursue their dreams
not facts not opinions its fears other
people imposed on you so why am i
sharing this message with you pad what's
the big deal about this message this
morning the message this morning is for
you to learn how to listen better and
what I mean by listened better is this
when people are speaking don't just
listen to face value on what they're
telling you ask yourself the following
when they're speaking to you they don't
know you're doing this where you should
be doing this do this is he imposing a
fear of fact or an opinion which one is
it my dad is imposing of fear ah ah I
don't know if I want to take this here
you don't need to say anything but you
at least not to fear from what he went
through or where your mom went throw
your teacher went through her girlfriend
went through because that's a fear you
can bring it up in that moment and say
listen it sounds like you're imposing
your fear on me that and honestly do you
really want your son to live a life of
not gonna you know fulfill his potential
now then please don't impose some of
your fears on me let me go out there and
do what I want to do my life no problem
or don't say anything
but regardless improve and learning how
to listen and differentiate between
fears facts and opinions actually test
it today and you'll see what I'm talking
about by the way questions thoughts
comments post your comments below and if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
do so let's have a killer week everybody
take care bye bye